[Music]
what's going on everybody comic con
2018. i am right here in san diego
california and i'm gonna talk to all the
people
and see all the things let's go
costumes humanity smells
a sea of people this is what uh
comic-con is all about
so one major challenge that people have
at comic-con
is crossing the street there's people
there's like uh law enforcement and
traffic officers
and there's trains there's cars
very true it's like frogger
almost
[Music]
we did it comic con 2018 we crossed the
street
i might get kicked out of comic-con
[Music]
noise noise noise smoking weed smoking
weed
that's all i remember of it i
am awarding you the laziest cosplay
award
isn't it awesome i was gonna do uh green
paint but i was afraid it was gonna be
humid
and it's gonna melt off that's the
opposite of dedication
it is seriously uh how are things in
king's landing
oh fantastic now that i'm on the throne
[Music]
i'm here with pennywise what smells
worse
the nerd funk at comic-con
or the sewer that you live in oh i have
to say it gets pretty bad at comic-con
true what makes you the best deadpool at
comic-con well
just because behind this mask is ryan
reynolds
wow ryan reynolds i didn't know you
spoke with an
accent a canadian accent that is a
canadian accent this isn't it from my
side of the of the canadian parts okay
we actually found jason mamoa for real
he's
right over there
[Music]
we also found this guy who cares about
aquaman when you have me
welcome to comic-con what up here at
purge city let's go in and see what it
takes to
have a good purge
let's say i wanted to go out and purge i
want to kill some fools
we do sell some armor here we also sell
some camo
we also sell tarps for the um post
purging
if you want to kind of wrap them up
let's say i want to take my sweetheart
out purging will you purge with me
will purging with my lady put her in the
mood anytime you raise your heart rate
with someone it creates bonding this is
science
those who purge together have the urge
together those who purge together
merge together i love that besides
murder
what crimes would you like to commit on
the purge i think a little arson
would be fun i might go into like a
restaurant and ask for a cup for water
and then go up to the machine and fill
it up with soda
wow i didn't get into any panels this
year and i'm not waiting online at hall
h
but i am still gonna break
some comic-con exclusive news
let's do this can you give us any
spoilers
for the next season game of thrones i
don't die
i live forever you heard it here first
exclusive do you have any comic-con
exclusives for us
hang on luke might not be done
hang on luke might not be done exclusive
we haven't seen the borg in a while
might they return
2019 november exclusive
i am always in contact the red tornado
is always ready to shoot in the movie
but i have not heard much
i keep on trying though comic-con
exclusive zangief
still unemployed what did you have for
breakfast oh just
coffee you heard it here first exclusive
do you have any comic-con exclusives to
drop for us
i have one yes i host karaoke
at the werewolf on 4th avenue
it's always a good time there five
dollar drinks
not what i'd call an a-plus comic-con
exclusive
but okay i'll take what i can get here's
a comic-con exclusive
kevin feige himself put that together
can you give us maybe an infinity war
exclusive
oh you know what i'm gonna leave that up
to tom holland to do all the uh the
spoilers
so if you find him around here i'd ask
him
that was a no
i am here with maybe the greatest
crossover event in comic-con history
uh hakuna montana
montana i can't wait to be king of the
cartel one day
say hello to my little friend simba ooh
let's see if we can get people
cosplaying as iconic characters
to say the wrong lines give me that
classic hulk line
hulk break poke break
eat my magic eat my magic okay avengers
let's take a break
did he actually say that i think so you
made that up go ahead and please say it
hey let's let's take a break right
avengers
don't have a cow man luke i am your
nephew
why is so serious when i snap my fingers
y'all gonna die
man space is pretty vast
hey guys want to grab some shawarma i'm
pretty sure he never said that
i think he said it it's probably in like
an outtake or something listen up
they call me the iron man where can
hella get a burrito around here
my brother bjorn is great at tennessee
by the power of grace go never forget
penguins mate for life can you give us
that other
classic star wars line
it's the only logical thing to do
i don't think that's star wars
exclusive project blue book is a new
alien encounters show
coincidentally i happen to have an alien
encounter last night
what were you doing at the time boozing
cruising
and losing you were walking around
downtown san diego drunk
i was also trying to get into comic-con
parties unsuccessfully
i'm shocked no one wants to party with
you how many objects did you witness
one object it had blue and red flashing
lights and it was going
[Music]
like have you ever seen the macy's
thanksgiving day parade
it looked like a giant garfield i was in
it
and then it was inside me and then i
woke up in bed
with a hangover i presume checks out
here it is my official report from
project blue book
yup i lived this
this should be in the newspaper as an
actual garfield cartoon
it's so amazing well we did all the
stuff
saw all the things talk to all the
people what more is left to do here at
san diego
comic-con thanks for watching i'm hal
rudnick hit me up on twitter and
instagram
bye bye